Hi everyone, in this video we're going to go ahead and animate a material in Unreal.
I'll show you how to connect all the nodes and get everything set up so we can have a
nice believable animation in our scene.
So let's get started.
So in this video we're probably going to break this up in a couple of videos here because
it is a few things you need to consider and there's a lot of options I want to be able
to point out so you can actually see the power and the ability you have to create what you
need in Unreal.
So we do have a sample material so anytime you are following along and you're like, hey
I want to see where Sean connected that and how did he get that to work, you can simply
go to this material here or this one that they're both the same and select them in our
Details panel and click on the magnifying glass to the folder.
This will take you directly to the sample material.
See it says it is under the folder called step 5.
So you can go ahead and double click on that and you can get an idea and pull up the material
as I'm working and you'll be able to follow along and you'll see that I have active notes
in here.
So let's go ahead and build a similar material.
We're going to be using kind of the same textures and that's fine within our scene.
So I'm going to go ahead to our content folder and I'm going to go ahead and go into our
class materials and we're going to make a new material.
So I'm going to go ahead and create material here.
I'm going to go and click on this and in material we will call this one M underscore animate
in CLL.
There we go.
So we're going to go ahead and animate this guy and let's go and double click on that material.
Let's drag him into our view here so we can see the whole thing and we want to go ahead
and grab the textures that we need.
Now some of the textures we're going to need, it can be any texture that you choose.
It doesn't have to be the ones that I have, but you'll notice in the Megascans we have
several different surfaces we can choose from.
If we open up surfaces you'll see we have wet stone ground.
You can use that one if you want to.
There's river stone and that's pretty much the one we're going to be focusing on is the
river stone.
So I'm going to go ahead and grab a few things here.
I'm going to grab my albedo.
I'm going to grab my AO just in case you want to punch some things into the AO as well as
maybe even mess with some metallic because this thing really doesn't have metallic, but
we could use the AO for that slot in this particular case just to fake a few things.
So I'm going to go ahead and for that note I'm also grab the cavity because maybe I want
to use that one instead and I could even use this place which is a little more dramatic
than the two.
I'm going to go ahead and grab the normal and I'm going to grab the roughness and I'll
also grab the specular because I might want to make this a little more highlighted to
make it a little more wet and we're going to go ahead and pull those into our scene.
Now you'll see there's a few others.
You'll see like there's gloss which can be used for spec.
You'll see that there's bump and this also could be used in different a variety of things
depending on how strong it is.
You could even have that as your AO.
Say you forgot to bake out the AO, you could use bump.
It's really up to you how you produce your textures and how what your DCC is for your
texture development like maybe you're using maybe Substance 3D.
We do have a plugin for that too so you can go into the plugins and pull and turn on our
Substance 3D but you got to make sure you go to their website to make sure you're getting
the latest one to be able to get that to work and make sure you're installed into Unreal.
Just want to give that quick call out to that because we do have tools to be able to accommodate
because not everything's built exactly the same.
When it comes to Megascans you can choose different things that you want like you could load your
cavity map and you can combine it with your AO to exaggerate some highlights and etc.
So you can set this up anyway that you see fit.
Alright so now that we have that stuff set up here let's go ahead and get our initial
texture set up the way that we want.
So we're not going to do anything fancy with the Elbido so I'm simply just going to grab
this and punch it right into the base color.
We just need this guy present and let's set this to a cube.
Now you'll notice my interface here in the previous videos that we had we were working
in 5.5 and this one I just kind of shifted to 5.6 just for the ending part so just so
you can get familiar to some of the icons I'm referring to.
In 5.5 you'll find out that the icons were down below when it came to your view are a
little 3D interactive viewer in here but you'll find them up here now when it comes to 5.6.
And that's okay they're just small minor changes but I just want to point that out if you are
following along and you'll see that this hey wait a minute this isn't 5.5 well I'm kind
of doing this one this section in 5.6.
Alright so we have this texture here let's go ahead and bring in the appropriate texture
that we can work with and in this case we can use gloss.
Now if you didn't grab gloss initially you'll see that we have cavity and you'll see that
we have roughness and you'll see that we have specular.
You can simply just go down here and it doesn't you don't have to have the same one to one
that I have if you don't for this particular slot where we're messing with metallic so
if you wanted to use gloss you can you don't have to you can use any one of these like
maybe even displacement so I'm going to pull up gloss and pull them in here and again the
thing you have to keep in mind if we are putting metallic on a non-metallic surface just be
aware that you can exaggerate things in in an area that you may like but it also may
push and pull things in an area you may not like and what I mean by that is you may get
too too much reflectivity so you can dumb that down and adjust your values accordingly.
Alright so let's go in here and plug this in so we're going to move albedo up a little
bit higher we're going to move this one over and again you can I'm not for this particular
lesson going to convert to parameter because you get the idea how to do that but you can
do that if you and I do recommend if you want to make changes on the fly let's go and keep
my finger on the M key in the child instance and let's go ahead and keep my finger on the
S key and left click so I'm I'm I'm again keeping my finger on that key and left clicking
to pull those up and I called up a scalar parameter which you saw me do earlier so let's get the
scalar parameter and set this to metal amount and again you don't have to do metal but I'm
going to show you the values of width on without and that can complement things depending
on the surface and the color values and the dark and light on an object some things may
not eat it some things may you may need to push that that little reflectivity a little
bit farther so I'm going to go ahead and grab this texture sample and I'm going to pull
that string into the a channel I'm going to grab that metal value and I keep it at zero
for now I'm going to pull that into the B channel now what we want to do is make some movement
going on here so we're going to have to grab another texture now this can be any type of
raindrop raindrops that you've chosen that you've made maybe you've edited on your own
it's up to you but I'm going to show you where you can get ours because we do have them available
you'll see underneath our folder underneath step five we have a folder called raindrops
so in raindrops we're going to go ahead and grab a few things for one we're going to grab
this particular one if we wanted to we could even grab this darker one if you wanted to
it's really up to you but I found this one that's a little more grayed out kind of a
smoother kind of drop effect here this one works a little bit better than this one and
it makes it less harsh between the contrasting and that's one thing you also have to be careful
and keep in mind if you're combining textures and stacking them on top of each other and
then plugging them into like a stronger value which maybe didn't exist in a rock such as
metal you might want to consider smoothing some of the values out and maybe using lighter
contrasting black and white textures so that's what I'm doing here so I'm going to go and
create an ad keep my finger the a key left click and I'm going to pull this string from
this particular raindrop into the B channel and I'm going to go ahead and grab the multiply
and put it into the A channel and we're going to have to need some movement here so let's
go ahead and create a panor so if you're not familiar with the panor node the panor node
allows us to be able to actually make motion from up down and even sideways if we punch
in the correct X and Y type of coordinates so I keep my finger the peakie left click
there we go we got panor now if I again if I wanted to move a little bit more to the
side I would mess with both these values but I really just want to be messing with the
Y channel value and in this particular case you can choose the speed I'm going to choose
a negative one there you go and I'm going to go ahead and punch that into my raindrops
if you want you can preview by right clicking and we can start preview mode to see what
it's going to look like that's a pretty good pace and I have it so that it's tiling so
we can go ahead and stop the preview and then we can go and punch that right into the metallic
and see what we get now we see this is what I like about it using it if I'm using a metallic
here that smooth makes it so it's not so harsh on the stone but you'll see movement over
the stone of the dark and light and you can change that if you wanted to if I wanted to
maybe I want the gray to be on the drops versus the white being on the surface and you got
to be careful with that because I want the white to be more reflective and you can see
it's slightly reflective in here not a whole lot because I don't have other values you
see a little bit better on the darker side but it's really up to you and this is what
you could do you could do like a one minus if you wanted to you can do one minus and
then we can flip that value now we get get into the one minus note a little bit more
in the other class after this but this shows you what you could do if you wanted to flip
it a little bit more and you can see that you can have it so actually that's actually
not too bad it gives you more of a higher reflective maybe type of look to it there
but again it's trying to use the texture that we have set in and it's really up to you what
you want to produce in your scene and that's actually not too shabby I think I kind of
like that alright so we'll leave that in there for now but we do get into that a little bit
more use of that into the other class so this is our initial setup what we want to do in
the next video is we're going to go ahead and elaborate on this a little bit farther
and we're going to push things a little bit more so we can get kind of the water effect
that we want to need thanks again